We focus on safety, specifically for our demographic: women.
So women really feel safe on our system.
Eighty percent of, many of our users in many cities are women...
...because they feel that this system can be tracked, it can be shared...
...so their husbands, their boyfriends, their fathers can track them...
...as they go home safely. So, that was the social front.
You're in five and you said soon-to-be six Southeast Asian countries.
Talk to us a little bit about what is Southeast Asia, why is it different...
...and this is sort of what makes you guys different from San Francisco.
One of the features is cash.
In the other apps, there are options of paying credit card.
In our case, we understand that, in the 600 million population,...
...a small, small slice of people are using credit card...
...so majority of people use cash.